- So now I'm going to
break the fourth wall.
And talk to you about the vlog.
In a macro.
Of why you guys
should be doing it.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
- [Gary] We have a short
day today in London.
We're even talking like,
"Oh what's the
vlog going to be today."
We're coming off
the court episode
that you guys have watched.
("Heaven" by Marc Aliotta)
One of the things,
while I've got most of you here.
I'm just extremely
impressed and grateful.
For the hustle that
this is office executing at.
We're working on a
lot of macro things.
There's a lot of
scenarios that are playing out.
Really separate from the re-org
that are just
London-based variables.
I'm just very impressed.
At the attitude and
energy of the office.
I just appreciate...
I just really appreciate,
I'm very grateful.
I guess that's
the way of the word.
So thank you.
And if you need me
for anything, I'm around.
("Heaven" by Marc Aliotta)
So now I'm going to
break the fourth wall.
And talk to you about the vlog.
In a macro.
Of why you guys
should be doing it.
The reason you vlog is just
nice young man just stopped me.
- [Man] Gary!
- [Gary] Yes.
- Oh my God, good to see you.
- How are you, good to see you.
This young man just stopped me.
- I followed
you for a long time.
- Thank you.
- You gotta get
back to earlier stuff.
- Wine?
- No before you were all
about motivational speaking.
- What do you
want me to get back to?
- I think I'm
not the only person.
I know some friends who agree.
They feel like you've
gone too much motivational.
- Too hype.
You know, I'm a human.
I got through ups and downs.
In 2009 I was on motivational.
- Just wanted to
let you know that.
- No I appreciate it,
I appreciate it.
- That people really
appreciate the substantive,
non-motivational
stuff you do, too.
- So what do you...
Tell me, I wanna hear it.
What do you...
What are the pieces of content
that gets the
most value for you?
- I think you've
already done a lot of the info
to non-motivational stuff.
And I think it's
just going deeper.
On the subjects that you
had previously talked about.
- Give me one or two.
- So I really liked it when you
went really
specific on social network.
On what you can
extract out of it.
- Like "Jab, Jab, Jab"
like that?
Like the more granular details.
- Yeah.
And even the early days
of Facebook ads, dark posting.
- So you know
what's interesting?
You'll like this.
While I'm calibrating.
One of the things
that I really focus on
is I don't want to talk
until I'm 100% positive.
Which is why I have
such conviction when I talk.
In Alexa voice,
in modern Facebook video,
in deeper
influencer marketing stuff.
I'm like this close.
And while I'm doing it.
I'm in the other part of me.
Which is I'm
excited, optimistic.
Call it motivational.
I'm empathetic
that it takes a piece
of the audience saying,
"Ugh, he's getting
too rah rah, too fluffy.
"And not detailed."
But I think that audience.
You and your friends
that are talking about it
are gonna really appreciate
is when I'm done crossing
my t's and dotting my i's.
On this next level stuff.
I'll go through a year or two,
or 18 months or 9 months
of more detail in it.
Even a moment like this.
Pushes me more
towards getting closer to it.
- One more last thing.
I think maybe a bit more
B to B stuff would be cool.
- Okay, I'll look at it.
- Okay, bye, good to see you.
- Thanks for
that feedback friend.
- Enjoy London.
- Yeah I wish you well.
You saw he gave
me critical feedback.
He's like, "Hey you're
getting a little too rah rah.
"I like back to details."
That "Jab, Jab" stuff.
You guys just saw it,
I don't have to explain it.
And now that is the
piece of content, right?
That's the piece of content.
That was an interesting insight.
That's a piece of content
that I can talk about now
to you as I'm
breaking this wall.
You never know
what's gonna happen
that's gonna lead to the thing.
And now you get to
watch it and see like,
"Oh, the thing can
happen out of nowhere."
That's the punchline
of the vlog.
("Heaven" by Marc Aliotta)